observer les étoiles à travers la plus
grande lunette astronomique de france et
contempler les astres c'est possible au
parc aux étoiles deuxième site le plus
haut d'île de france il est situé en
plein coeur de la forêt de l'hautil à
triel-sur-seine sa position lui permet
de s'éloigner de la pollution lumineuse
le musée au sein du parc permet d'en
découvrir un peu plus sur l'astronomie
et l'astronautique grâce à un médiateur
scientifique
la visite se déroule dans cette première
galerie commence il y à peu près
13,5 6 milliards d'années dans ce qu'on
appelle communément big bang
progresse vers la formation des galaxies
des explications sur des phénomènes plus
complexes comme par exemple les trous
noirs ou la formation des systèmes
planétaires la seconde galerie du musée
s'articule autour d'événements majeurs
comme le premier satellite artificiel
spoutnik ou encore l'arrivée de l'homme
sur la lune en 1969 et pour les plus
passionnés la grande lunette
astronomique est ouverte au public
elle permet d'admirer le soleil le jour
ainsi que la lune et les planètes la
nuit commune est charles à poil donc qui
a été réalisé
en
1895 gustave eiffel voilà c'est un
instrument exceptionnel
jusque c'est la plus grande menace de
médiation scientifique en france autre
outil cette camionnette nommé léonard en
hommage à leonard de vinci premiers
ingénieurs de france le parc aux étoiles
sillonnent ainsi les yvelines pour
apporter la science en dehors de ses
murs léonard su aussi s'y télescopent de
type dobson qui nous permettent
d'intégrer des sites d'observation un
peu partout sur notre territoire rendre
accessible l'astronomie et la science au
plus grand nombre et susciter la
curiosité scientifique dès le plus jeune
âge voici l'ambition du site durant les
vacances scolaires il organise des
ateliers pratiques pour les enfants de 5
à 16 ans il dispose même de sa propre
chaîne youtube du permettant de
vulgariser certains sujets toujours avec
un aspect ludique